um okay so let's talk about let's
continue our discussion monopolies last
time we talked about monopolies and sort
of talked about how there's sort of a
another extreme of the market structure
spectrum we have perfectly competitive
firms where there's facing a perfectly
elastic demand curve and competing with
a essentially infinite number of other
firms and taking prices versus a
monopolist who owns the market and sets
the price but therefore faces this
poisoning effect which leads them to
under produce and creates deadweight
loss so today we want to continue our
discussion op Elise with three sort of
separate topics okay the first topic I
want to cover is where do monopolies
come from so sort of the Stork does not
bring monopolies they come from
somewhere else and sort of where you
know so sort of how do monopolies arise
and there's really two sources of
monopolies that I want to focus on today
the first is what we call but is
monopolies that arise from cost
advantages the opposite arise from cost
advantages so some markets come with a
natural built-in cost advantage for one
participant so it could be there's like
an essential input like there's one rock
quarry in town okay and like whoever
controls the rock quarry they supply the
rocks for the whole area um in that case
we say that this is an example of a
natural monopoly a natural monopoly a
natural monopoly is one where is a
market where for all relevant quantities
one firm can always produce more fish at
a lower average cost than another firm
can so for all relevant quantities one
firm can always produce at a lower
average cost than can other firms okay
this basically is the same as saying
that it's a marker where average cost is
everywhere declining at least in the
relevant production range you can
imagine where you know so for some crazy
quantities average cost increases but
we're average cost is everywhere
declining is a market with a natural
monopoly so why would this be true let's
consider I think as a simplest case
let's think about a water utility
delivering water to people's houses
through pipes underground okay once
those pipes are laid okay
it is that the giant fixed costs are
paid and the marginal costs are trivial
it's the cost of the water the fixed
cost are so large relative to the
marginal cost that average cost always
declines in our typical production
function remember average cost first
declines then goes back up if first
declines you pay off the fixed cost then
back up as the rising marginal cost
start to dominate this is a market where
that second part just never gets big
enough say where marginal costs are
close to you know Mart where we're
essentially marginal productivities
close to flat so the marginal cost curve
isn't rising that fast and/or the fixed
costs are enormous okay so we could see
that like in Figure twelve one imagine a
water utility which has roughly flat
marginal cost that is the marginal cost
as the cost is procuring another gallon
of water now once again at some point if
you want to give every person in America
one millions of gallons of water it
would marginal costs would start to rise
but for the relevant range it's roughly
flat and yet there's enormous fixed cost
you got to lay those water pipes so in
that world average cost is everywhere
declining it asymptotes it's approaching
marginal cost but it never crosses
marginal cost okay in such a world once
one firm has laid the pipe since
providing water it never makes sense for
another firm to enter never man engineer
make sense why is that because if
another firm thinks about entering Vegas
they oh look this this water till is
making all this money this would be
great market to enter remember we talked
about unlimited entry and exit and
perfect competition I draw
prophets away well let's say another
firm says look at all this profits I
wanted to this market the first firm
will say I'm just gonna tell you right
now if you enter this market I will
price at marginal cost until you leave
for the first firm they've already paid
to lay down the pipe so as long as the
pricing and marginal cost they're not
losing money but for the second firm
they keep they will lose money if the
firm stays at marginal cost so they'll
just never enter because they know the
first firm has a barrier to entry they
have a natural monopoly having laid down
those pipes having already paid that
fixed cost that sunk they will win any
battle they'll just price at or near
marginal cost and drive any competitors
out of the market okay
so these kinds of essentially natural
monopolies arrives when enormous fixed
costs create a barrier to entry okay
when enormous fixed costs create a
barrier to entry you could see natural
monopolies and that's a one common way
monopolies arise in the world think of
utilities is sort of you know like
delivering water as a classic example
that so that's one way we get monopolies
the second way we get monopolies is
through government action governments
also create monopolies remember today I
told you we talked about governments as
good guys but there's also still
government's can do things which are can
create deadweight loss and now sometimes
governments do this for a good reason
like a natural monopoly reason like the
postal service for example local postal
delivery delivering letters locally has
all the features of a natural monopoly
it's a huge fixed cost of building all
the post offices and a small marginal
cost of transmitting letters from place
to place
now however in other cases it's not
necessarily true and the rest in the in
the u.s. we have very few government
created monopolies the rest of the world
especially developing world is much more
common many countries have the
government control the production of
steel all the production of the
airline's are controlled by the governor
um banking is often controlled by the
government these are places where
probably evidence suggests it would be
more efficient to not have the
government control this there's no real
natural monopoly in banking but it's
more for political reasons that they're
created but that's not really that
relevant in us even the post office
isn't a monopoly anymore right with
FedEx and UPS and stuff so so it's not
really relevant in the US the second the
more relevantly for the u.s. wait the
government freights monopoly is by
creating barriers to entry the
government could create barriers to
entry the most prominent which is
patents the most prominent barrier to
entry is a patent this is the case where
the fixed cost here is into building a
pipe it's coming up with an idea and the
base of the government has a law which
says that if you have a new idea and you
patent it you are granted a monopoly to
sell the resulting good for 20 years
from the date of patent okay so when you
patent a good you regret you granted the
right to a monopoly over that market for
20 years essentially government is
creating a monopoly it's saying once you
patented that now remembers not very
importantly especially for drug
development it's not the date at which
the good comes to market it's the date
at which you file so if you file for a
patent and it takes you 19 years to
develop the product then you only get
one year monopoly in the market so it's
the some 20 years as both the
development period and the sales fair
you get 20 years from the date you file
okay now patents are quite interesting
because the welfare implications are
kind of mixed on the one hand um a
patent by creating monopolies creates
deadweight loss okay for 20 years you've
got that weight potentially up to 20
years you've got deadweight loss in that
market because one firm has the monopoly
rights to sell the good okay on the
other hand why my patents be a good idea
yeah
right because research and development
is a huge fixed cost and if you pay that
huge fixed cost in the minute you
develop it someone else can just copy
you then you never invest those fixed
costs okay so basically we talk it we'll
talk about this we'll talk later in the
course about externalities but you think
of this is sort of a positive spillover
from R&D when firms do R&D when a firm
invents something it benefits everybody
who might produce that good so if I
invent something then everybody you
could copy me could benefit so I will
not invest in R&D unless I can be sure
I'm gonna get some money out of it and
that's what the patent does it reduces
those spill overs by saying okay you get
to own this for 20 years and make some
money on it therefore go ahead and
invest in other words what a patent does
is essentially the government saying we
are gonna you're you're going to get a
reward for being first to market and
that reward is 20 years of privilege of
being a monopolist in a market therefore
that's an incentive for you to go and
invent yeah you know that that's a very
detailed concept that's I don't have
time to get into but there's a whole
bunch of legal battles around that but
the bottom line is there's a patent
trade-off here the trade-off is on the
one hand it's sort of a static what we
call sort of a static versus dynamic
trade-off sort of today versus the
future at any point in time there's a
ton of deadweight loss out there because
monopolists who have patents are under
producing at the same time over time we
are getting cool new products because of
patents and that's the trade-off and
that's sort of how did twenty years get
picked ideally you'd have some optimal
period to resolve that trade-off the
Altima resolve the trade off long enough
to get creation but short enough to not
so that the games in that creation don't
exceed the dead weight loss for monopoly
okay and that's an example how a
monopoly can arise from a government
action and the point is that for both
national monopolies and patents there
are legitimate reasons for monopolies to
arise so what I want to say is
monopolies are not bad they're not a
necessarily an inherent flaw in the
system okay there are legitimate reasons
to have monopolies both because of
natural monopolies and because a patent
but they do at any point in time create
deadweight loss yeah it's a great
question there are people who do spend
their lives doing that and basically the
way you'd want to do it is essentially
the way you would do it is you would
essentially measure the consumer surplus
created from the new good versus the to
be the triangle sizes be how much
consumer travels to get from the good
versus deadweight loss from that good
sales being restricted now obviously if
it's a good that never would have
existed otherwise by definition that
patent is a good thing because who cares
about to have a loss of you never would
have had it in the first place the
question really is about the
substitutability if you're patenting
something which only incrementally
better then maybe it's not worth it
so that's sort of the trade-off ok other
questions ok so now let's talk about
addressing or regulating monopolies
let's go back to think about our sort of
natural monopoly case ok let's think
about our sort of natural monopoly case
ok
XO I'm going to call this X you're not
regular calls addressing monopolies
because addressing anomalies about
different ways that we can address
monopolies and we'll go back to our
natural monopoly case to make it easy ok
the first way we can address monopolies
is through government regulation so
let's step back here the bottom line is
we have a monopoly this should exists a
natural monopoly
it exists actually at the same time that
is creating a deadweight loss is
creating an efficiency so the brilliance
the insight of the first fundamental
theorem of all four economics was the
competition through entry and exit will
bring us the efficient production level
and reduce deadweight loss here with a
Nash monopoly that doesn't work
competition can't work therefore we end
up with a deadweight loss because the
firm that owns the market is under
producing ok this is the first case as I
mentioned last time of what we call a
market failure the market outcome is not
delivering the welfare maximizing result
and once there's a market failure
there's a potential beneficial role for
government as said last time with no
market failures government's just a bad
guy with no market failures all
government government is not all
government can do for an efficiency
perspective it can help with
redistribution but an efficiency
perspective all the government could do
is muck up the market but once there's a
market failure there's a potential role
for the government addressing it ok so
to see that let's return to our Monopoly
exam from last time ok and figure 12 to
figure 12 2 is our monopoly example from
last time remember we had demand curve
that was Q equals 24 minus P we had a
cost curve that delivered the marginal
cost of MC equals to Q and that's
graphed here okay and we said last time
that the monopoly outcome would be at E
sub n the monopolist would sell 6 units
the price of 18 creating a deadweight
loss of C plus C now what if the
government came along and simply
mandated that then the monopolist was
not allowed to charge more than 16 the
government says look I understand it's a
monopoly I'm not gonna try to break up
the monopoly it's natural monopoly
whatever simple rule price ceiling of 16
now when I mentioned prices a couple of
lectures ago you should have learned to
say boo price ceilings bad creased
deadweight loss terrible
but now suddenly a price ceiling can
actually get rid of deadweight loss
how's that possible
let's take a look in this case the
monopolist new marginal revenue curve is
a bit different okay the new larger
revenue curve is the old marginal
revenue curve until you get to the point
where the first dashed line intersects
marginal revenue okay it's it's the old
marginal revenue curve until until you
get where the marginal cost crosses
marginal revenue then it jumps to the
flat line at 16 so it's basically the
new marg revenue curve is basically um
essentially the new marginal revenue
curve is downward-sloping till the point
where march Costco's marginal revenue
then it jumps back up to the flat part
that goes from 6 to 8 okay
now the exact shape doesn't matter it c
tuition that matters the points of
following think about the monopolist
decision he decides based on launched
with last time to sell six units that's
the point where the poisoning effect
offsets the benefits of selling another
unit now let's say the government comes
it says monopolist you can't charge more
than 16
well once again a post is forced to
charge 16 now think about her decision
to sell the seventh unit okay well
before she want to sell the seventh unit
because sell in the seventh unit meant
she had to lower the price to seventeen
well now she has to lower the price to
16 already so why not sell the seventh
unit indeed why not sell the eighth unit
the monopolist is we've essentially
gotten rid of the poisoning effect by
pre poisoning them but I already fell in
look you can't charge more than 16
there's no way to make charge more than
that so you might as well sell eight
units okay so by telling the monopolist
they have to charge the competitive
price you will force them to sell the
competitive quantity and you get rid of
deadweight loss and that's our first
example of how
government has improved things the
government has gotten rid of the
deadweight loss by setting a price
ceiling price ceiling in a perfect
market is only bad but a price ceiling
here can actually improve things okay so
that actually sounds pretty good so
what's the problem why not in reality
just say hey we can solve all Monopoly
problems by just having the government
and regulate the price at the
competitive level what's the problem
reality with that solution yeah
how the hell was the government on the
competitive levels great with this chart
but in reality the government doesn't
know where the competitive level is
because there's too difficult points
what does the government need to collect
first of all the government needs to
know what the demand curve is well it
turns out demand curves aren't like
written on our foreheads are out there
and you know in in on the dark web okay
demand curves are something which you
have to estimate you have to gather
information from people and it turns out
that it's pretty hard because if you
want to get other information on what
people are willing to pay for apples you
can just go to stores and look at the
prices charged for apples but if you
want to gather information than willing
to pay for getting water delivered to
your house there's no market to turn to
okay
they turns out to be pretty hard to
figure out how you value a lot of goods
which is natural monopolies now you
might say well why don't just ask people
what it's worth to them just say to
people look tell me you demand for water
turns out that's really hard because
people aren't very good at thinking
about how to assign prices to things
they don't shop for okay if you think
what an apple is worth your first thing
if I say to you what's an Apple worth
the first thing your head is you think
about being a supermarket looking at
apples and what that cost you don't
think about the inherent value to you of
consuming an Apple okay but when you
think about what water is worth you have
to think about sort of the inherent
value and so you have to rely on
something that we call contingent
valuation which is the economists fancy
word for just asking people what it's
worth to them okay the problem is people
aren't very good about that
so for example a classic case was the
rise in environmental issues how much is
it worth to have clean air how much
worth to save the Grand Canyon so it
turns out people give sort of crazy
answers that violate any norms of
violate all the rules we set up in the
first lecture by utility functions like
for example if you ask folks what it's
worth to save the Grand Canyon as a
single question and then you ask them as
the third question on the list it's
worth one-fifth as much to save the
Grand Canyon it's the third question on
the list
does it make any sense doesn't matter
what the other questions are if you ask
people how much they would pay to save
seals and whales in that order they'd
pay saving seals is worth one hundred
and forty two dollars and whales one
hundred ninety five dollars well you ask
tenants pay whales and then seals so
whales and seals are about the same but
when you reverse the order whales are
worth about twice what seals are worth
just by reversing the order or more
relevantly if you ask you what's what
it's worth to save a bird or ten Birds
or a thousand birds or million birds
they give you pretty much the same
answer okay which doesn't make any sense
so basically the problem is has
continued valuation methods don't really
give sensible answers and it's very hard
to get sensible answers and we can talk
in my other course polyatomics we talk
about lots of interesting clever methods
for trying to get people to reveal their
preferences for these public goods but
it turns out to be hard so that's one
problem is it's hard to mention demand
curve the other problem is it's hard to
measure the supply curve because we're
the supply curve comes from its from a
firm's marginal cost function you as the
regulator do not know what their
marginal cost function is so how do you
find out you ask them you say hey
business I'm gonna regulate I'd like to
know what your marginal cost is and by
the way the lower you tell me it is the
lower price I'm gonna let you charge so
what's your marginal cost Oh God our
marginal cost is horribly high terrible
you wouldn't believe it
cants can't complain enough about a
higher marginal cost this and basically
the unless the regulator perfectly knows
the production function and perfectly
knows the input price is none of which
are perfectly known by anybody but the
firm they aren't could know what the
supply curve looks like what the
marginal cost looks like question
you can absolutely do that and you can
try to collect data but ultimately they
could that day they show up with the
inspector have a have a really expensive
looking setup in their factory or
whatever it's basically very very hard
so both so basically um the problem is
that regulation and so gentle be a
feature when we talk about the benefits
of government intervention well say
there's market failure makes it possible
that government intervention can make
things better but not definite so the
way to think about the logic is in a
perfectly competitive market with no
market failure government intervention
only makes things less efficient
we're leaving redistribution aside all
makes things less efficient when you
move to markets with failure you open up
the possibility the gum intervention can
make things better but not for sure that
it will you open up the possibility but
not it's a necessary but not a
sufficient condition for saying the
government improves efficiency so for
example imagine that the government came
in to this market and said we think the
competitive price is 10 okay we these
better prices 10 well if the government
set the price equal to 10 we know that
firms produce where marginal cost firms
are going to produce where marginal
marginal revenue which is now just 10
because it's regulated equals marginal
cost
so we're 10 equals 2 Q 2 Q and little
qbq are the same right because the
monopolist we're 10 equals to Q or where
Q equals 5 so if the government comes in
and says we're fixing a price of 10 we
know the firm produce 5 units well with
5 units the deadweight loss is even
bigger
right the key trick would dead weight
loss triangles dead we lost essentially
proportional to how far you deviate from
the optimal point so the more you move
to the left
the bigger the deadweight loss triangles
gonna get so Dave I lost with five units
sold that's bigger than their weight
lost with six units sold so the
government's actually made things worse
by coming as taking this price of 10 the
government's made things worse okay
indeed the governor could actually set
price solo you shut down the government
set the price below the shutdown point
and wipe the whole wipe the whole
business off the map so here we have the
trade off the government can potentially
make the market more efficient through
price regulation but it won't
necessarily it depends on its level
information how well it does send the
price for all over to the competitive
price okay um so basically this is a
very sort of interesting and difficult
problem for the government so the other
way the government can try it so one way
is through regulation take questions
about that the other way to try to
address monopolies is by saying is there
some way to introduce competition that
is even in what feels like a natural
monopoly market is there some way to
choose competition okay so for example
think about broadband delivery okay now
we're still wired and the future it's
all Wireless is it different it's still
wired okay the way it works is broadband
delivery has features of a natural
monopoly which is someone has to lay the
wires to your house to deliver it okay
at the same time once those lives are
wise we're late it's a zero marginal
cost to allow you to connect to the
internet so what governments do in other
countries but not the u.s. in the u.s.
we have competition everybody lays their
own lines down okay in Europe they
recognize that's inefficient it's a
natural monopoly what they do is they
have one set of publicly laid lines and
you compete to deliver content over
those lines
so there's competition where the
monopoly is not natural which is over
the delivery of it which is over the
speed and the quality it's the quality
the connection but the lines themselves
since that's the giant fixed cost they
realize there can't be competition over
that so that's one way you could try to
deal with the natural monopolies in
other words the government could control
the pipes under the ground delivering
the water and that firms compete over
delivering the water to you okay so
that's one way to deal with it another
example is to think about the public
sector and think about education
education deliver now for those of you
who grew up in the u.s. okay
you are evidence of the success of the
u.s. educational system but you are the
exception not the rule
okay u.s. educational system by
international standards for four is very
badly we're kind of probably out of the
top 30 countries we're like 15th in
terms of things like math scores and
other things like that
um yet we spend more money per pupil
than any other education system in the
country by a large amount as you know
system in the world by a large amount
okay so if you look at figure twelve
three figure twelve three shows in the
blue primary cool spending per pupil and
in the red a frayed maths course and you
can see the US spends way more than
other people but our scores aren't any
better indeed it doesn't look like
there's very strong relationship here at
all
between how much beat how much country
spend and what you get in return but at
least it's quite striking how low the
u.s. is given how high our spending is
okay now why is that one reason is
because we have given local schools a
monopoly we have said to local schools
you have monopoly where you get to
deliver the education anyone who lives
within a certain radius of your school
okay we've created that we've created
that natural monopoly and once you
create that natural monopoly we reduce
pressures on firms to produce
efficiently okay we've essentially said
to firms you monopoly there's no reason
you have to produce efficiently okay we
have reduced because there's no entry
and exit which can cause you can put
those pressures on you so in some sense
that's a government created monopoly
right your local public school is a
government created monopoly so what can
we do for that what can we do what we
can actually introduce competition so
for example we could have public school
choice which many cities now have where
in fact you don't have to go to school
in your neighborhood you can go to you
can enter you can try to go to any
school in the district you can
essentially enter a lottery
and try to move around to other schools
in the district and that is competition
because then the schools that want kids
will have to be better and have to
produce more efficiently and actually
and then a further modeled mode of that
is we can do you can have charter
schools charter schools are publicly
funded but not City provided there
there's in between public schools and
private schools okay
charter schools are separate schools
which are paint which get funding from
the from the government but they aren't
under the local governments control
regulatory control but they aren't
delivered by the city as education and
that provides more public school choice
for individuals and there's a lot of
evidence much of it by my colleagues
here at MIT which shows that there's
been enormous benefits to these
movements the public school situation
charter schools have delivered now I
know tell me - unseen the john oliver
segment a couple years ago he ragged on
charter schools that was i mean i love
him in general but he was wrong on that
one there's a couple bad actors but by
and large charter schools have been
enormous benefit to the education system
by choosing competition and getting
allowing students an option to improve
their educational outcomes
okay now the furthest out option and
something i hear a lot of discussion of
is vouchers those radical option is what
we call public school vouchers or vet
just vouchers here's how this would work
there's a very popular idea on the
conservative side of the spectrum here's
how this would work so i live in
lexington what that means is if i send
my kid to a lexington public school it's
free but the men and I pull my kid out
and send into a private school it cost
me the entire amount
so imagine Alexa public school education
is worth ten thousand dollars okay I get
I'm essentially getting ten thousand
dollars conditional on sending my kids
to Lexington school the Mennonites you
send them elsewhere
I literally give up that ten thousand
dollars okay a voucher system would say
the way it would work is everyone in
town would get a check
or we get a voucher for $10,000 to be
used at any school they want so if you
want to go in Lexington just hand it in
it's just enough lice never changed but
now if you wanted a private school we're
allowing to take your money elsewhere
that puts competitive pressure not just
on schools within a district but on the
whole district the whole district now
says wait a second if we don't do a good
job people are gonna leave and take
their money elsewhere so the idea is to
actually set up broader competition to
put pressure on districts to improve the
performance okay so this has been a
longtime attractive option to many
economists and I spent I've spent a
whole long time talking about the pros
and cons this in my other class but
briefly speaking the pros are all the
reasons we like competition and markets
okay to cause more production efficiency
because schools would have to compete
the cons are numerous though one con is
you didn't have to make sure you then
have to have the public sector then as a
vested interest in making sure private
schools are delivering a public quality
education so I have a great you know
basically you can set up a private
school that it's just a football
training academy and suddenly people
could take their voucher and go there
and suddenly they wouldn't get education
that's one con another con of these
systems arm is that they're expensive so
think about so take me I live in
Lexington pretty rich guy I sent my kids
to private school okay I sent them and I
paid an Imagine Lexington a voucher
system and they given me a check for
$10,000 why should Lexington give a
relatively rich guy $10,000 that's sort
of silly I was already sending my kids
to private school so who would be the
big winner from a system like this well
some winners would be kids who'd then
get a better education but a lot of
where's having rich people already sent
the kids to private school you just be
handing them checks that's not a great
outcome so there are definitely
trade-offs in a system like this
inherent in a system like this um and
there's a lot a few questions let's do a
couple of questions I'll move on yeah
the back so say like you have these
vouchers and instead of going to the
public school students are leaving to
the private school and then the fixed
costs are like having like the
infrastructure of a public school that's
then spread out
over less students so how do you account
for like the price of teaching one
student might go up if there are these
students that mean that is an awesome
question that there's two elements to
that question one is there is an actual
natural monopoly feature to local public
education so we remember competition
doesn't make sense when it's a true
natural monopoly there is some natural
monopoly elements so as you strengthen
number you you suddenly are raising the
average cost and that is a potential
problem there's an efficiency she was
also an equity issue which is who uses
the vouchers and leaves the people with
motivated parents who are with it who
gets left behind people's parents don't
give a [ __ ] about them okay there's an
equity issue too of suddenly you're
pulling all the smart kids of a
motivated kids out of the public schools
and leaving the kids behind you our
motivators parents aren't motivated
there's an equity issue there too so
that's another trade-off yeah I know
people get a good education well that's
right that's another problem which is
competition one of our fundamental
assumptions of perfect competition was
perfect information that's fine when
you're looking at apples or maybe even
computers it's not so it's not so easy
looking at schools now schools publish
test scores you can leave the test
scores of kids to go to that school but
once again that's not that reliable
because as smart kids are going to
school have high test scores either the
teachers suck okay
for example Harvard sorry I couldn't
resist so so so basically you can't
really tell um that so I grew infirm it
another problem in other words we're
taught there's a number of failures of
the private education market that are a
problem with this kind of voucher
solution but this but it doesn't mean
it's wrong it means it's interesting
okay there's a trade-off on the one hand
we need to choose competition which
would maybe increase efficiency in the
market on the other hand there's a lot
of market failures might get in the way
of this functioning properly fascinating
topic and if you want to learn more I
urge you to take 14:41 we spend a whole
lecture talking about it okay so that
was the other second topic I want to
talk about which is once again we've
started down the road of questioning the
wisdom of the market
okay we said so the world of market
failures okay the first market fellas
monopoly we've talked about the pros and
cons of trying to deal with monopolies
but I want to talk about one of the
topic we're gonna before we leave
monopolies which is this topic of what
we call contestable markets which is
sort of an informal tongue but I really
like it as an intuition so I like to
spend some time on it
contestant markets are monopoly markets
without market power over that much
market power that is we talked about
monopolist as having lots of market
power remember we said the markup was
essentially proportional but we said
that monopolist had a markup price minus
marginal costs over price which is equal
to minus 1 over the elasticity of demand
ok that was their markup and so you know
some markets different monopoly markets
those different levels of market power
you can be a monopolist but not of much
market power if consumers are very
elastic but there's another reason why
monopolist face pressure
besides the elasticity of demand which
is some sense the size of the barrier to
entry so one reason monopolist are
constrained in the priciest because
demands elastic another reason is
because the barriers to entry might not
be that large so you could think of it
roughly speaking for a given elasticity
of demand the larger the barrier to
entry the more market power you have
because the larger the barrier entry the
more you can be sure no other firms
going to come in or in other words the
amount to which in charge above marginal
cost for a given elasticity is
proportional to how severe are the
barriers to entry are if there's no way
a second firm can get in then
essentially you get to just obey this
formula but if a second firm can get in
easily then you might not even be able
to have this bigger markup because if
you try someone's gonna come in and
steal your profits okay so in other
words there's essentially an important
issue which is that the market
monopolist can get as a function both of
lasas demand and the size the barrier
sentry
this an important issue that came up in
the area of airline deregulation which
is what I want to talk about we've been
talking about now um how do you see how
many of you seen Mad Men geez really ok
it's pretty good job I'm it's not static
yeah
how many seen Breaking Bad ok good ok
that you have to all see Mad Men's
pretty good ok but basically what's nice
about Mad Men it shows what flying was
like when I was a kid ok when I was a
kid when you flew it was like luxurious
ok you went on there was plenty of
legroom you had like free meals free
movies free drinks it was uh and
basically um that and the reason was
because well I've sort of skipped ahead
in the story when I was a kid
airlines were regulated what that meant
was that essentially um the government
viewed Airlines as a natural monopoly
they said look planes are very expensive
there's a big fixed cost so it's a
natural monopoly we don't think
competition will work well here so we're
gonna have regulation of Airlines what
that meant was the government set the
price of every flight and regulated
where planes could go so Airlines
however you would submit a set of routes
they wanted to fly in a set of prices
and the government's would approve or
turn them down
okay it was a regulated market okay and
it was generally viewed the government
basically sort of screwed this up and
set the rates too high that was sort of
general view that base the government
because essentially and really
understand the supply curve they're
being sort of fooled by the manufactory
costs were higher than they were and
we're setting prices too high okay but
economists said look this is not a
natural monopoly because in fact it's
not actually that cheap to get a use
plane and enter this business okay
because these companies turn over their
planes all the time and yes buying a new
planes expensive but getting a
well-functioning use plane isn't that
expensive and you could easily create
competitors in this business they said
is what we call a contestable more
a market with very low barrier century
that in fact if you allowed competition
you would have a lot of entry into this
market and it would function fine that
it wasn't natural monopolies a
contestable market ok and they argued in
fact that if you like competition price
would fall very close to marginal cost
okay price of fall very close to
marginal cost
so in fact economists carried the day
and the 1970s we deregulated the airline
industry the government stopped setting
prices and regulating routes what
happened okay three three things
happened the first thing is price fell
enormous ly the cost of flying fell by
about a third
okay the best example was the airline I
took home from MIT in 1984 called
people's Express people's Express their
laws introduced this was sort of shortly
after deregulation I could fly from
Boston to Newark for $29 okay now how
did that work it was crazy showed up at
the airport there was no reservation
just waited online they let people onto
the plane was fold when you waited for
the next one
you paid on the plane with the credit
card I still didn't they don't know what
happened if you didn't pay they throw
you out the window I don't know but he
paid on the plane and it was incredibly
competitive and this is what happened
flying got incredibly cheap okay the
second thing that happened is you've had
many more reps it turned out that the
government thought that flying from
point A to point B wasn't profitable
often when it was so the government
wouldn't let Airlines flight up from
point A to point B when in fact Airlines
couldn't make plenty of money you in
that flight
she had cheaper flights and more routes
okay the third thing is flying sucks
okay I was a kid flying was awesome
meals booze big seats now it's terrible
no meals no booze tiny seats okay why
why did this happen why did we suddenly
go flights got cheaper than more of them
but why did they say why
we suddenly why would they suddenly
crash yeah right that's one way to put
it but what there's all the point is
what this example points out is that
there's always competition yeah what we
gonna say wasn't they still praised
screaming it wasn't quite that but yeah
they were really fly but what were they
doing before yeah like a review right so
there were multiple lines before the
government said wooly compete on price
but they said great we'll compete on
other stuff
remember economic actors wanna be
economic actors they want to use
economic tools okay
so if the government says to the
airline's we're not gonna let you charge
a higher price they're like great we'll
compete by having better food better
drinks bigger seats okay once the
government said now you have a new mode
of competing they realized people
weren't willing to pay for better food
and better drinks and bigger seats
they'd rather fly cheaper so they'd
switch the mode of competition from
quality competition to price competition
they used to use quality competition now
these price competition this means that
all of us who complain that flying sucks
should just shut up because we really
cared that much then there'd be a good
airline that charged more and gave you
better stuff but there's not any
JetBlue's a little better but like by
and large okay there's not airlines that
charge more you'd be better stuff okay
and that's because the end of the day we
would rather fly cheaper than have this
extra stuff it wasn't worth the money
that we're paying for it okay so which
really says that regulation was failing
here regulation was forcing Airlines to
compete in the inefficient way they're
competing us by giving us nice meals we
would rather when we rather have the
money so it's example that regulation
failed okay so that's all really good
news but there's one piece of bad news
which is that economists aren't
all-knowing and the economists there's a
fourth outcome we missed
which was the rise of the hub-and-spoke
system which is that what we missed is
that airplanes aren't a natural monopoly
but airports are and what Airlines
started doing is essentially taking over
Airport slots okay and then saying we
are gonna have all the flights so for
example my wife's from Minneapolis we
used to go to Minneapolis the only
option is Northwest Northwest Oh - all
the slots in Minneapolis Airport and
they say if you ever fly anywhere on
Northwest we're gonna write you through
Minneapolis - wherever you go
okay what's called the hub-and-spoke
system you always want your central
point went out so US air had Pittsburgh
you know Northwest said Minneapolis and
American had Dallas etc they these hubs
you go through what that meant was they
essentially got a monopoly on the route
into the hubs because they didn't adopt
Leon the slots at the airport so now you
might say well that's easy to fix don't
get monopoly slots in the airport but
that's harder to fix than you think
because whenever the airport in
Minneapolis was saved Northwest we want
to allow other airlines they say great
we're moving our headquarters out of
Minneapolis see ya and they say okay
fine we won't do that so essentially
these there became political equilibrium
where these local airlines were such big
employers they bullied the government to
delaying them dominate the airports and
they essentially recreated a monopoly
but then ah Polly wasn't on planes he
was on airport slots and actually flying
got much more expensive again so flying
really so the price of flights really
came down until Airlines figure this hub
and spoke system and they've gone back
up since now there's still cheaper than
they were under regulation but I roughly
speaking at the price price fault
fell by more like more than 50%
initially and they're sort of risen back
up it's still lower than it was under
regulation but it's risen back up
because there's a sort of new natural
monopoly problem that we didn't um that
we didn't see okay so at least the crazy
things like you know a price of a
nonstop to San Francisco today is
something like half as much from Boston
as a flight to Minnesota now I know your
geography skills are but San Francisco's
a lot farther from Boston and Minnesota
is so it's clearly not a marginal cost
issue okay so that's an example
is sort of a nice case study of kind of
our motivation was right by and large
economist got it right bylaws were
better off in a deregulated world okay
but not as well off as we thought
because we missed this other element
natural monopolies okay um so that's
that's why I stopped there um we will
continue next time by talking about
oligopoly